[Music]
with our lifestyle nowadays a lot of us
do suffer from lower back pain our
bodies function at their best when our
muscles work in sync with one another
weak muscles especially around the core
and pelvis can lead to back pain and any
unwanted injuries so if you do suffer
from back pain I'm good to share with
you the do's and don'ts when it comes to
movements and exercising these exercises
will have to strengthen your lower back
to prevent any unwanted injuries and for
you to lead a healthier life
avoid situps many might think that
sit-ups can strengthen the core or apps
but more often people tend to use
muscles in their hips instead of their
abs when you sit all the way up you're
lifting your tailbone off the floor and
this movement can actually cause more
pressure on the spine which can lead to
injury and pain on the lower back so if
you have a lower back pain or injury you
should definitely avoid this exercise
perform partial crunches instead partial
crunches are more effective at isolating
your abdominal muscles and prevent
excessive back stress when you crunch up
tighten your abs and only rise to where
your shoulder blades come off the mat
don't use your arms to pull your neck
off the floor your hands should gently
support your head hold for a second
right at the top then lower back down
your feet tailbone and lower back should
remain in contact with the mat
throughout
avoid double leg raises double leg
raises can help to strengthen your core
but it can put a lot of pressure on your
lower back especially if you do it wrong
or if you already do suffer from pain
this exercise should be avoided for
those with weak core or lower back by
lifting the tailbone off the floor and
arching the lower back it can create
discomfort thus making your pain worse
take it slow and perform knee to chest
instead instead of lifting both legs
together lift one at a time lie on the
mat with both legs stretched out then
bring one knee close to the chest
keeping the other leg on the floor then
lower the leg and repeat on the opposite
leg remember to keep your back flat on
the floor throughout the workout and do
not lift your tailbone off the floor
this workout strengthens the lower
abdominal without putting excess
pressure on the lower back next avoid
Superman Superman is actually a really
great workout to strengthen the lower
back muscles however if you're someone
who suffers from existing injury or
extreme pain avoid this exercise without
a strong core you might struggle to lift
both of the arms and legs off the floor
simultaneously this can cause you to
compensate on proper form and recruit
the wrong muscles when performing of
exercise some might even over arch your
lower back and jerk as they come up
which can create high amounts of stress
and discomfort to their lower back
perform birth talk of bridging instead
birth dock is a great exercise to
strengthen and stabilize of the lower
back and core without overloading the
spine start on all fours keep your back
flat and tighten your stomach muscles in
a slow and controlled manner lift and
extend one leg behind you and the
opposite arm hold for one count slowly
lower back down and switch to the
opposite side
be careful not to let your lower back
sag and dip your hips only rise to the
height where the lower back position can
be maintained or perform bridging lie on
your back with your knees bent and arms
by your sides push a huge into the floor
squeeze the glutes and lift your hips
off the floor unto the shoulders hips
and knees are in a straight line hold
for about two to three counts then
slowly lower the hips and repeat this
exercise strengthens the lower back hip
flexors and also glutes to help
stabilize the spine and to give you
proper posture avoid standing toe
touches most of us still think that
touching that toes is the best way to
stretch at their hamstrings and improve
flexibility but the truth is they may be
putting even greater stress on the discs
and ligaments in their spine toe touches
from a standing position can aggravate
pain and some might even over stretch at
the hamstrings and lower back muscles
perform hamstring stretches instead
tight hamstring muscles are one of the
most common contributors to lower back
pain the hamstring muscles run through
the back of each thigh from the hip down
to the back of the knee so to relieve
lower back pain perform hamstring
stretches regularly over time this will
lengthen and reduce tension in the
hamstring muscles hence reducing stress
felt in the lower back lie flat on your
back with your knees bent look at our
around the calf of one foot straighten
your knee and slowly draw your leg
towards you you should feel a gentle
stretch down the back of your leg don't
force at the stretch only go as far as
you can without bending your knee
whole for at least fifteen to thirty
seconds and repeat on the other side be
sure to keep your back flat on the mat
throughout the stretch avoid squat jumps
generally you should not be running or
performing any jump based exercises the
high impact from the movement will only
create more stress on your lower back
which can lead to further injury and
slower recovery if you experience back
pain or discomfort after performing jump
based exercises chances are it is due to
poor posture or a tight muscle so check
your form and take it a notch down as
you strengthen the weak muscles perform
wall squat instead this is a low-impact
workout that does not put any strain on
the lower back yet it is extremely
effective in strengthening your legs
glutes hip flexors and also core simply
find a spot against the wall then stand
about one foot away
lean back until your back is fully flat
against the wall then slide down until
your knees are bent at a 90 degree angle
pressing your lower back into the wall
and hold for about thirty to sixty
seconds as you progress you can perform
basic squat off the wall but still
making sure that your back is flat chest
up and your fully engaging the muscles
in your lower body so stop doing
exercises that can hurt and wasn't
you're already fragile back and start
performing the right and safe exercises
that can actually help you relieve back
pain and strengthen your back and core
to prevent any further injuries or
stiffness aim to perform each exercise
for fifteen to twenty repetitions and a
total of two to three sets perform these
exercises regularly and you will have a
stronger call and it will also increase
your flexibility be sure to LIKE this
video share it on with someone who might
be suffering from lower back pain to
help them through it do also check out
more workout videos & fitness tips on my
channel hit the subscribe button and get
notified when I upload new videos every
week all the best